[man speaking indistinctly
over walkie-talkie]
- FRONT OF HOUSE IS CLEAR.
- HUH?
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
- MUST'VE BEEN NOTHING.
- BACK PATIO'S CLEAR.
[woman laughing]
- [grunts]
- [gasps]
- SHH.
- NOW IT'S MY TURN TO PLAY.
- [snaps fingers]
[gun cocks]
[woman screams]
[guns cock]
- [gasps]
OH.
- [chuckles]
CAROL.
- [gasps]
TEAGUE!
- I THOUGHT I KILLED YOU
THE FIRST TIME, MR. TEAGUE.
I PROMISE I WILL NOT MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKE TWICE.
- [breathes deeply]
- YOU ARE A GOOD COP,
MR. TEAGUE,
BUT A LOUSY FIGHTER.
- UGH! AH!
UGH! UGH! OH! UGH!
UGH! OH! UGH! OH! UGH!
OH!
- NO! TEAGUE!
NO!
- OH, SNAP, MR. TEAGUE.
[body thuds]
- SNAP INDEED.
- OH.
[chuckles]
TEAGUE...
YOU SAVED MY LIFE.
- NO, CAROL...
YOU SAVED MINE.
[bones crack]
OH.
OH, [bleep].
[bones cracking]
THAT'S JUST--
[bones crack]